(whooshing)
- Hello Believe Nation,
today we're going to learn.
- Seven ways to find your passion.
(techno music)
♫ Nine, eight, seven
- So one of the most common
questions that I get asked
when I got into this is
how do I find my passion?
- We also received that
from Tzoghik Petrosyan.
- Who's from Armenia and is
one of our YouTube viewers
and so we thought, we're
going to share our seven ways
on how to find your passion.
(techno music)
Number is immediately
explore and the idea here is
whenever you come up with
an idea that you think you
might be interested in,
instead of letting it sit
and sit and sit and weeks
go by and months go by
and you've done nothing
about it, just go out
and find some small way
to get started on it
to see if it makes you come alive
and if you want to do it
again and again and again.
(techno music)
- Number two think about
what makes you happy.
When you wake up in the
morning, try to observe
what makes you happy,
what's the best thing
that you're looking forward that day?
Is it the cooking, is it
hanging out with your friends
or your family, do you
want to go out dancing
or your actual job makes
you happy, you want to
go and get things done,
you're excited the change
you're making in somebody's
life or in the corporation
as well, right, so just
think about what are the,
maybe, a few things
that you're excited for.
Is it working with the people,
doing something for others,
just hanging out with your
friends, enjoying the music.
I think once you look into
those clues, you would have
more ideas on what it is
that you want to do in life.
(techno music)
- Number three is say yes more.
If you don't know what your passion is
and one of the easiest ways to explore
and find new things is say yes.
If your friends invite
you out to do something
that you've never done before,
normally you might say no.
That's not me, that's not scary,
I've never done that before.
Get into the habit of saying yes more.
So that may be going
snowboarding, it may be going
Salsa dancing, it may
be joinin' a book club.
You never know what it's going
to be, say yes to experience
it and see if that thing
makes you come alive or not.
(techno music)
- Number four, model your heroes.
So for example, me, I'm
really passionate about
Michelle Obama and I follow her every day.
I watch her videos and I follow
what she's doing in life.
The reason I do that is
because I realize I'm really
passionate about all the causes
that Michelle Obama is passionate about.
She really likes to help
kids, she really cares
about kid's involvement,
the future, opportunities
for them and giving
everything you can give
to the kids because they're our future
and I find that same thing for me.
By following her, I also
realize how passionate
I am about kids, not only
about having my own kids
but any time I'm in the
environment of kids,
it just makes me happy, I look at them
and I see so much potential in them.
So I believe if you follow your models,
you can also find your own passions.
- Did you hear that, Alex?
Ruzanna is passionate about having
her own kids, just so you know.
(techno music)
Number five is remove the
pressure to have it work.
So many times when you're
starting something new,
it's a first time going
out trying something,
you put so much pressure
that this has to be the
thing that you're going to
fall in love with where a lot
of times, you need a little bit more time.
Just like if you are going
out on a date with somebody,
if that has to be the one
and you put so much pressure
on yourself that that has to be the one,
then it's probably not going to work out.
Where you want to allow for
time for things to happen.
And so as an example, in
the Salsa dancing business,
when I first started Salsa dancing,
it was a fun thing to do.
I never put so much pressure that
this had to be my business.
And on paper, I was really
tall so I took big steps
which isn't good, I didn't,
ya know, learn the music
growing up, I don't speak Spanish.
All of these things were
against me that if I went into
that first event thinking
like, this has to be my next
thing, I probably would've
left and never come back to it.
Because I put too much pressure on myself.
And so don't put that
much pressure on yourself
that that has to be the
thing that works out
your first time through,
give it some time,
play with it and see where it leads.
(techno music)
- Number six, travel more,
traveling, similar to
what Evan mentioned earlier,
saying more yes to your
friends or family will help
you explore more ideas.
And when I say travel,
you don't have to go all
the way to Africa or
to India or the Belgium
or anywhere else to
find out your passions.
You can go to the next
community, you can go to
the next city and see what
people are doing there.
What is it that makes them
happy, what, like what
other activities are they doing?
It could be skiing, it
could be snowboarding.
It could be going out dancing, similar to
what Evan and I, if you
travel more and be open to
more ideas of experiencing
new things, it will
also help you with finding your passions.
(techno music)
- Number seven is try anything once.
I like to adopt the mentality
of I'll try anything once.
Even if I maybe have
tried something similar
and it didn't have results, I'll
still go out and try anything once.
As an example, take that
approach to I'd try ski,
snowboarding, I tried rock
climbing and I tried Salsa
dancing all in the same year
almost and the rock climbing
I tried once and I hated
it and the thing was
in my crotch.
- That's awesome.
- And I was uncomfortable
and right, like some people
love it like Ruzanna.
- I do.
- Me, I went once, was
like okay, I said yes.
I tried it once, I'm done,
snowboarding, I picked it up.
I loved it, I became
obsessed with it for ya know,
a season and a half and
now I go once a season,
twice a season, although
I haven't gone this season
so maybe it's going and
Salsa dancing I tried once
and I liked it and I
came back and ya know,
ten years later, still
dancing, still having fun,
owning and business and so
just adopting the mentality
of trying something once,
whether it's going out with
a friend or something,
whether it's seeing an ad for
something that you want to,
you know, potentially try,
whether it's somebody
offering you new food
that you're going to test out.
When you get an opportunity
that you haven't done before,
just get into the habit of saying I'm
going to try it once, give it a shot.
So that's our take on the Seven
Ways To Find Your Passion.
- And we'd like to know
which one you like the most
and if you'd like to
add eight, nine or more,
you can also add it in the comments.
- Leave your thoughts down
in the comments below.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
We believe in you and hope you continue
to believe in yourself.
- Believe.
- And remember, your one word is,
much love guys, we'll see you soon.
(whooshing)